when i was a kid there wasn't a lot of
spare money in our house to spend on
fancy ingredients but mum was brilliant
at what she did let me tell you so we
had really tasty hearty food great cakes
amazing puddings all made with the
freshest ingredients that's right isn't
it yes
let's get this show on their old town
we're cooking the kind of food mum
always dished up starting with a family
favorite steamed eight pudding with a
glorious butterscotch sauce
they weren't cool desserts on those days
were they no it was puddings puddings
now
i'm gonna sieve the flower would you
i'll chop here sean chop those dates
please
that was a favorite wasn't it amazing
sew it in
okay but it's almost like an
old-fashioned dessert wasn't this themed
and everything was sort of steam you had
jam really poorly mm-hmm
so the zest the orange makes that really
nice and fragrant so it helps get that
richness to the suit
okay yeah
brown sugar in
this is such an easy recipe
yes looks fantastic on the table
and then treacle
cheek it in
oh look at that
there's something quite
magical about a spoonful of treacle can
you add them in there please
thank you they'll do and crack an egg
lightly whisk it and mix that into the
milk
if i pour in the egg and the milk would
you give that little mix up please yep
thank you
nice nice and slow
don't go too fast
you see i always used to think that it
was an old-fashioned desert steamed
pudding do you ever remember me
tumbling around your knees trying to
sort of get in there yeah so you like to
lick the ball didn't you all the time
yeah
now
lightly grease
the mold you're always willing to help
but not with washing up some things
never changed i think i was allergic to
the soap how was your excuse
kids will enjoy this tonight won't they
delicious paper
that goes on so the secret behind the
parchment paper is to keep that nice and
tight tight yep
there we are
good yeah oh hey wash my hand
come on
tightly cover with foil and place in a
pan of water and let it steam for around
two hours with a lid on
are you going to wash up gord
just for once wash up mr ram oh dear
goodness
do you like that smash
mom you handed it to me and you dropped
it come on
whilst mom forces me to break the habit
of a lifetime dude that's the thought
you're washing up it does that to you
here's how to make an amazing
butterscotch sauce to serve with the
pudding
add butter into a pan
brown sugar
golden syrup
and a pinch of salt
and vanilla seeds
melt and combine over a medium heat
stir in the cream and simmer until
thickened
that's the taste of my childhood inner
jug right there and it will keep in the
fridge for a week
[Music]
now for the main course my all-time
favorite shepherd's pie what's the
secret
behind a really good
shepherd's pie
i would think the vegetables you use and
growing in it
so we're going to use leeks
and onions and then start browning off
the mints you know no color no flavor
i've never forgotten that you know that
yeah
so
good half color gotta have color
otherwise it puts that grey tinge on the
shepherd's pie that looks sick greasy
and cheap and nasty
they don't want that do we and i know
you don't do cheap and nasty let me
clear your peelings now
all right thank you very much there's no
nails in there now is there no
don't be chicken
i remember
your
amazing shepherd's pie
and that lovely little restaurant used
to work in sheep street in stratford
so you never got food sent back
no sometimes they complained that there
was no
come on no i'm telling you
you never ever got a complaint no
how long do you work at that restaurant
for
six shoes six shoes
oh hello chilly
what are you cooking i'm gonna make okay
i sort of modern version of nanny's
shepherd's pie dad shouldn't manny be
doing the cooking because she's the
better cook excuse me right mum would
you would you chop our onion please
darling yeah oh gosh your eyes are gonna
water
daddy what's in this spot sorry
in there we got a delicious steamed
treacle and date pudding
um how do skeletons call their friends
how do skeletons call their friends i'm
not too sure on the scalabone i'm just
gonna tilly come on
okay so two cats are in a race one is
called one two three and the other is
called
under 12. who won
john depends who's the fastest cat one
two three because under 12 cats sank
[Music]
oh goodness
why do you make a nice cup of tea for
honey you want me to disappear
thank you
bye so give that a little fry off okay
nice
quarter these jokes they get worse oh
she's certainly having a bit of fun
booster sauce worcester sauce that's
going to give that really nice spicy
seasoning
oh thank you oh that's hot you okay yeah
tomato puree in
you could put a ton of tomatoes in this
if you want you could yeah put that
mince back in there once it's drained
i'm just gonna put a little touch
i know you'll go crazy at this a little
touch of red wine
really
why the red wine well because i'm gonna
make it nice and rich
okay
reduce the red wine down yeah and then
start covering your mince
with your stock
now i'm gonna bring it up to the bowl
okay and then get some fresh rosemary
okay
like little taste yes please
is it hot
it's a little bit hot be careful
well i don't like the way
i'm sorry
oh god
as it cooks out the wine and the alcohol
will disappear it will be delicious
trust me
now god spring onions will chop up
and that's going to go through
the mashed potatoes it's going to sit on
top of that nicer i like that savory
yeah delicious mince that's laced with
all that red wine nice so sprinkles into
there please mum
and i'm going to drain off the potatoes
hi there hello hello
oh hi jack hi hi hello hello josh have a
nice day school yeah
so i'm gonna dry out those potatoes and
then mash them
no oh can i mash them would you okay um
holly slice a little knob of butter in
there for jack please
so what was the restaurant you worked
out there were you a chef
cook
i love the diplomacy were you a chef i
was a cook
exactly that
no really
you used to help me with these little
right you kids do no potatoes
these are nice and fluffy aren't they
aren't they and you want them little
delicious mashed potatoes yeah with no
lumps in there
hey what are you getting at
huh
it's great having you back in the
kitchen mommy now yeah seriously brings
back good memories
no
just
why'd you do that dad i just want to
fork it to get it nice and spiky
so i want that nice crispy topping and
then lightly grate that cheddar cheese
on top and that goes in the oven
literally 20 minutes 180 minutes jack
can you up the door people
that looks lovely doesn't it
even though you said you didn't like it
earlier okay
back in the day mama's meals all came
with two veg and this is no different
but with a modern twist braised peas and
carrots with a fantastic homemade mint
butter
shepherd's pie
glazed on top that looks lovely doesn't
it doesn't it
and then the carrots
oh seeded coats that's why i didn't put
carrots in let's put them on the side
i'll see last job before serving pour
that gorgeous butterscotch sauce over
the pudding
okay i'll take one at a time
that smells incredible
this is my ultimate childhood dinner
shepherd's pie with crispy cheese champ
topping sweet buttery peas and carrots
and a steam date pudding dripping in
butterscotch sauce eating mess bomb
right eat a mess what's the one thing
you love about easter mess i love the
meringues now this is a eaten mess
with a twist
what's the twist in it compared to the
normal one we're going to freeze it so
it's almost like a sort of eaten mess
bomb
wow now i'd like you to whisk the cream
please
half the strawberries are going to go
through the mix and half the
strawberries are going to be turned into
a coulis strawberries in first a little
dusting of icing sugar into the pan and
now the icing sugar will withdraw the
sweetness from the strawberries and
start caramelizing so let me show you a
nice quick way of whisking secret
whisking
is like 10 seconds on
and 10 seconds off
that way your arms don't get tired
now
i'm going to take the cream to a
three-quarter stage what is a
three-quarter mix so we leave some sort
of texture in the cream
that's what we call
three-quarter whip and you've got a nice
soft peak
they're caramelized there you go you put
a little touch of water in there that'll
help
break down the sugar
and turn that into a really nice
strawberry liquid
now to get it really nice and fine i'm
gonna blend it
on
and blitz
off
okay that's fine i want you to use the
back of the spoon
and push that
through the sieve okay now that way you
don't get those seeds smells so good i
love this now nice this is the exciting
part
hold on oh meg
right now the meringue with your fingers
just crush and flake the meringue into
the cream how big should i crush it dado
there
nice big chunks
okay lovely
oh okay yeah come on rang in my eye damn
to make this dessert even easier i often
cheat by using good quality shot port
meringues you know taste that's just
cream and bread
wow it's a little tasty okay
strawberries in next a couple of spoons
of the cooling
now look at that now
to prepare the mold to transform the
traditional eaten mess into a frozen
bomb form a triple layer of climb film
adding water to the bowl will help the
climb film stick
as i pour that in i want you to spread
it down okay at the bottom and push it
down can you hear that crunch yeah the
line all right
now
fold the cling film over
put that in the freezer please
make young please
in the freezer she goes
[Music]
dessert done now for our main course
with a twist that is the rib eye we've
had that in the fridge not wrapped so it
sort of almost air dries and it
intensifies the flavor gross so much
quicker and there's less water in the
beef
for me the only downside to perfect
roast dinner is the fight about who
washes up afterwards
so meg and i are going to avoid that by
cooking everything in one roasting tin
starting with the spinach and mushroom
stuffing
[Music]
let's do it with a salt and pepper
please good girl
some of your left shoulder left shoulder
thank you
in with the garlic and the mushrooms to
toss the pan you push down and pull back
down and push back off you go take your
time
push it down
and flip very good that's it push down
nice that was lovely and again
nice i'm gonna drop let's see well done
well done well then right we're gonna
sort of make a little well a little
touch of butter in the middle now i need
to start putting the spinach in the
middle piece
so you can push that down spinach is
cold so you're not going to burn
yourself
be confident in the pan
toss it and you'll see it wilting
and disintegrating away wow who would
have thought all that spinach could fit
in this pan because it's a very delicate
leaf it sort of cooks so quickly put
this all on your board now
and then i just want you to go
and give that
a nice chop then when you're confident
with one hand
we need to pick up the other knife the
other hand
chop it nicely
good
now outside and come in gently
good regroup
and take your time
yes
mmm right
i love that smell what is that lemon
thyme lemon tan that's right so you get
your little thyme stalks and you pour
down you sort of strip
lemon thyme in now tarragon it'll taste
brilliant with the beef
fantastic with chicken and fish roughly
chop the target and i sprinkling fresh
breadcrumbs
so the breadcrumbs almost sort of bring
the stuffing together
next we're gonna get an egg yolk
now with the beef this is the exciting
part
slice
with the bone and then come inside and
go two thirds of the way down
hold that open for daddy salt
and pepper
and then look we pack our stuffing in
there
this is amazing it's incredible now just
gently hold out there like that okay
yeah i'll see you tomorrow what
tying string around the rib will keep it
all together during roasting not too
tight if we tie it too tightly what
happens the stuffing will come out
that's right
that's ready for roasting but we're
going to protect it and sit it on a
trivet
so a trivet basically is almost like a
sort of little little bed a little bed
that's right
if you want to enjoy these delicious
roast vegetables at their best make sure
you remove them from the hot oven after
35 minutes and reheat before serving
with your beef
now a little mix for the top a couple of
teaspoons of mustard powder in salt
a couple of tablespoons of olive oil mix
that in
i'm gonna pour my mustard powder over
the beef so this forms a really nice
glaze
my one pot roast dinner goes into a hot
oven 15 minutes at 230 degrees then down
to 170 degrees for another two hours
for a delicious twist on traditional
yorkshire puds i'm going to lace mine
with fresh horseradish
with plain white flour in a bowl
and crack in the eggs
adding only half of your milk at this
stage makes it much easier to whisk all
the lumps out
and if like me you like your puddings a
little lighter and crispier add a
dribble of cold water and add salt to
season
when you're happy your batter is lump
free whisk in the remaining milk
peel and grate horseradish
and add a handful to the mix
we can leave the batter to rest while we
get the meat from the oven
that is beautiful and this is where you
really need to let it rest how long
would you say to rest it for um i like
to rest the meat for at least 20 minutes
just the right amount of time for us to
whack up the oven and to get our
yorkshire puddings in
i love using the rich dripping but
vegetable all is a healthier option
to get the fluffiest yorkshires your
tray and fat must be piping hot
for best results take your jug of batter
to the oven and pour the mixture in
there
it takes just 15 minutes for our
yorkshire puds to puff themselves up and
turn a delicious golden brown
with the yorkshire puddings on the way
and the beef rested we can finish off
the eater mess bomb run the bowl
under the hot water
twist
and pull
nice wow look at that beauty
it's amazing sit that
on
to your plate
now the finishing touches a drizzle of
the remaining strawberry coulis i'm just
gonna pour this over an amazing flavor
and some grated mint chocolate
and that is a nice twist
on a classic eaten mess a delicious
eaten mess bomb
beautiful let's go baby
please don't drop that meg please it's
not a rounders match
dessert sorted and the beef is ready to
serve up lift that up place that onto
the board
parsnips parrots you can see why we kept
them in half they've got all that flavor
one beautiful big slice
for daddy
one for maggie and then on the side it's
stuffing the stuffing a bit that's the
best to die for
now fantastic yorkshire they're amazing
aren't they beautiful mm-hmm that's been
my darling
and that one that's for me
beautiful roast beef
with a twist wow
[Music]
these are my ultimate classics with a
twist
juicy river beef with horseradish spiked
yorkshire puds
and scrummy eaten mess bomb topped with
strawberry coulee and mint chocolate
what are your favorites a marshmallow
and peanut fridge cake
perfect for
a picnic first things first you have to
slowly melt the chocolate
that's bad that's good
i'm gonna break up the chocolate
right in there next butter goes in
couple tablespoons of golden syrup
it's so good if we melt chocolate too
quickly it starts to separate and
destroy
the best and safest way to melt
chocolate is always use a bain-marie but
i'm going to keep a really close eye on
mine and heat it over a super low heat
this stunning little cake has your
favorites in there our digestives now
put your hands in there and give them
like that one at a time ago
and crush what's the one thing that you
love about a picnic
i love eating outside especially on a
nice summery day
not so much in the winter no
that's gonna be the crunchy part of our
fridge cake
and it's called a fridge cake because it
can sit in the fridge or you can freeze
it now the peanuts in please
can you use it without peanuts if you're
allergic to peanuts oh you can do yeah
definitely no
what are these little babies cranberries
cranberries
from there
marshmallows my favorite okay
they're so bright aren't they why do you
love marshmallows so much because
they're so squishy all right give that a
nice mix up
chocolate is melting nicely okay i want
you to pour that in and i'll mix it nice
and gently slowly slowly slowly soon
nice
now
touch more please
good isn't it good give that a little
mix with daddy please they're all melty
and nice and cool and gooey
now we're gonna line the tray
so this is quite easy to make because um
you don't have to bake it
you just set it yeah i want you to start
pushing it into the corners please with
your fingers just laying out nice and
flat
ah it's all nice and marshmallow and
oozy
to get pulled spatula okay and look
how delicious does that look
really delicious i can eat it right now
i couldn't because it's not set
all right so when that sets okay
it'll go nice and firm and then we can
cut it into little bars little squares
triangles triangles
push push good
but the important part of pushing it
down is that we can slice it
and the more we push the thinner we can
slice okay
good girl
[Music]
fridge cake done
now i'm gonna make the most amazing
anchovy dip with vegetables and bread
first cut slices of baguette and bake in
the oven at 180 degrees c for six
minutes or until crisp
meanwhile roughly chop garlic and
shallots and add to a food processor
along with a tin of good quality
anchovies
[Music]
sprinkle in some pitted black olives
flat leaf parsley and drizzle in the
reserved anchovy oil and a little olive
oil
blitz to a paste and add pepper
then decant into a jar ready to
transport
serve with a handful of fresh baby
carrots
peppery radishes and your crisp baguette
toast
anchovy dip a portable and deliciously
palatable alfresco treat
[Music]
now a spicy chili yogurt dressing with a
prawn salad first things first i'd like
you to make the dressing
fish sauce
doesn't really smell like fishes so one
and a half tablespoons of fish sauce
two chilli
i like this especially if you have it on
the side of the pork
little teaspoon of sugar
oh that's it good
in
so four tablespoons of yogurt
three
four
some zest in there
why are you making it in a jam jar not a
bowl well this is for a little picnic
and it's a great way of transporting
we squeeze the lime in there and then we
put the lid on shake it
and then i want you to shut it on tight
[Music]
it's a bit like a tummy
see
that sounds like my tummy
only sometimes only sometimes thank you
for that
kind of gives you
and the first time you have it's like a
little thingy it's fresh
salty citrusy
but delicious now cucumber and the salad
i want to get rid of all the seeds so if
you just nice and gently
peel
the cucumber why do you feel it can you
not eat the skin on it you can eat the
skin but i want this salad to taste
light
and fresh you can use a knife for this
too though can't you you can peel with a
knife but a speed peeler takes off the
slices nice and thinly so much quicker
so much quicker that's why it's called a
speed peeler
looks better now looks a bit naked it
does look a bit naked doesn't it
now you get your spoon
and see
what happens
a teaspoon just takes out all those
seeds
so whilst it sits in the dish
it doesn't make the salad go all soft
because that cucumber is nice and
crunchy
[Music]
that's really good
there you go so see where your knuckles
are there
that's what's always going to protect if
you put that little finger out
this little piggy
boom comes off what did i tell you about
daddy's knuckle that's the first place
you cut off
all the time there you go
the next addition to our prawn salad is
firm juicy baby gem lettuce
look at the lettuce in half what about
the butt
the butts
[Music]
i'm keeping the butts on for now so when
i slice it it stays together
okay
and then
a little bit there
we don't use
okay
when you prepare lettuce for picnic you
never slice it too thinly
okay otherwise it will it's good prawns
already
your tummy sauce is ready your dressing
is ready take the lid off
and the trick is
you dress
the bottom of your dish because i'm
gonna put the prawns on here to protect
the lettuce
get your cucumber
i put my cucumber on
and then finally that is
okay
now the salad is not going to go soft
why is that because it's not that it's
not straight onto the dressing that's
right
what happens is we wrap this now and
then we get to our picnic drizzle the
sauce on top we mix it up we've got the
dressing on the bottom and the dressing
on top
of the dressing on top that's right
a little bit of tim film do you know the
cling film trick i don't know the
tinfield trick yet no thing fell over
the top of the toilet
what you don't understand it when you're
my age
oh you've been my age then well okay
salad in the fridge with the dressing
ready to go for a picnic
this is my ultimate picnic dinner feast
prawn and cucumber salad with a spicy
yogurt dressing
anchovy dip with crudites
and the kids favorite chocolate
marshmallow and peanut fridge cake